professor
what is this i hear about you downsizing
the x-men
do you shower with those on what do you
shower with your
sunglasses on the the laser beam
controlling sunglasses you shadow with
them on of course i do otherwise of
course you do obviously otherwise if you
don't you'd be uncontrollably shooting
laser beams that kill everyone instantly
just willy-nilly from your eyeballs no i
would never so let me ask you what
basically is protecting me and everyone
here from certain death
um well i'm i'm careful
be careful
you don't ever let loose with a corona
maybe you want to whip them off did they
even have some sort of chain on the back
so if they did fall off you could find
them quickly no that would
not look cool
oh
why'd that orphanage get leveled scott
didn't want to look like a door but i am
the leader of the x-men the leader yeah
so great what are you going to lead us
to the hospital after you winked at
rogue and took off her torso that's not
going to happen toasted okay what about
sex excuse me what about during sex you
ever
i don't know get tempted to see a beach
that isn't red tinted you just whip them
off in a fit of frenzy and then
prematurely shoot
red beams all over jean grey okay leave
her out of this please no more jean grey
just a pile of ashes that's it's also
gray
double gray goodbye my love okay
professor i do have the moment you were
born we should have cut your head off
you were a message from god that he
doesn't love us and we should have sent
it back sign sealed deliver return to
sender except if you were in heaven it
would be hell
what are you gonna do without me
probably cry myself to sleep every night
with tears that don't harm anyone oh
okay you know what i i normally look
people in the eye when i fire them but
in this case seeing as that would kill
me and everyone about a mile behind me
i'll say to your ray-bans get the out of
my house you nerd
thanks nerd
nice sunglasses by the way you look like
you're on your way to a bachelor party
at a hooters do you drive a honda
motorbike or is that just your face